welcome to this video playing Alexa the
national master lexa from Israel he had
his name in that one time maybe do the
Trump again I had a good win recently
with that here in blitz see fine i think
it's d5 don't really know it so well i
know that this is the virginian gambit
which is very dangerous for black queen
bee to be should be too and widest
pushing a for FY and that's it's really
not so easy for black Wow
i don't know i mean this does this
almost makes sure that i'm going to play
okay he can play e5 now maybe but other
than that it all overall it almost make
sure that I get to play e5 his light
squares I'm immensely week if I if I
don't know I mean I have root be one
Queen B 5 check to get back the pawn
that looks dubious for black yes this is
the possibility let's start let's start
with this if he takes d5 i have e 5 and
this is going to be very dangerous okay
night chief I it takes a 95 maybe
or start with that it's difficult there
are many continuations like that look
that look promising here night b5 queen
bee five check can take and play Quincy
for then many many good good
continuations actually not easy to
determine what is Sam what is the most
promising try to pray to player to play
quickly here Quincy for was my idea TSD
five-night b5 also this e five yeah I
mean as mentioned it all is dangerous
95mm that still looks look somewhat
playable for black which is probably
more than he should have
hmm yeah
yeah that's not really what I wanted to
do but how to to do something else by
now and yes 96 now this is the problem
I'm not sure I can punish punish this he
cannot castle at least there is always
some kind of compensation but but I
really feel that it wasn't the best
possible way to play ok so i can give I
can check on on on here and play Queen
age 6 check may be threatening Queen g7
it's still a very good compensation
maybe maybe I'm too critical here and
it's okay queen e 5 I can maybe also
just take b7 all the check probably the
check is the sorry the rookie one I mean
attacking not the check attacking the
Queen there is no check in the position
at all right probably this is radium
rookie one but Queen g7 has a very
dangerous threat yeah okay maybe it was
ok all along but I was a little bit more
yeah I think here right if he goes if he
does not check me now on g4 I play a
queen ji sang and non-threatening rookie
6 and I don't see how he covers it
night f8 for example this Bishop f6 well
it's a queen d 5 Queen g7 and that's it
now that sets lost here I don't listen
to move here all night b6 is this still
northern is still Bishop f6 cannot move
the night yeah just to give blacks King
a square on d7 G Alice's this is really
lost leaf I've also Queen g7
yeah this whole line with queen bee
sixes it is very very young very very
risky now that's better than rookie six
after rookie six King be 7 i'm not sure
how I'm winning and here I have an idea
getting the rook is good it's a lack
resign it's a whole rook yeah around
here I don't know Bishop g4 looks very
dangerous for black no went here this is
this and now the comp gives night queen
bee five check and just taking on b7
yeah that's the simple way to play but
it seems to be good okay I tried this
but it's also seems to be good you five
yeah that sits in fact the computers
mainline take stakes and Castle Sam ate
it I wasn't so sure in the game but it
seems to be excellent why does why does
clearly better him yeah well this is
plus seven mm-hmm roop ki one and
however is given us better than than
this or at least not so good what
happens there I couldn't be five yeah
okay yeah this is okay jack but this is
also winning yes yeah plus 11 so
probably there's also made around the
corner yeah I wasn't so sure during the
game but when you see it afterwards and
can ask them computer it it looks very
devastating okay thanks for watching